if I'm right and I think I am
Tesla's new model D is going to be an
upgraded version of their existing Model
S but not with one but two motors one
driving the rear wheels one driving the
front the new car will be faster more
powerful more efficient and will
continue Tesla's efforts to bring fully
electric vehicles to the masses but as
far as the masses are concerned there
are still a ways to go the existing
Model S already cost nearly $80,000
that's more than twice the average
amount people spend on a new car in the
u.s. adding an additional motor to the
Model D is not going to make it less
expensive much of the development and
alternative powertrains Toyota Priuses
and Nissan Leafs notwithstanding is
happening in cars priced for the country
club set
recently mercedes-benz started selling
its Tesla powered b-class electric drive
it looks like a Toyota Matrix but it
could set you back more than $50,000 BMW
has its i3 electric hatchback which may
be small on the outside but it's big in
the MSRP a fully loaded model to get you
real close to $60,000 car tech is a
little bit like Reaganomics it's all
about the trickle-down think of a major
technological advance in cars and the
likelihood is it started on a very
expensive model anti-lock brakes
Mercedes s-class fuel injection another
Mercedes the 300 SL disc brakes the
Citroen ds4 going to pioneer an entirely
new and very expensive technology it
helps to pass the cost on to people who
can afford it then over time the cost
reduce and you can apply that new tech
to cars of all prices which of course is
Tesla's plan after the company releases
a family-friendly crossover it's
expected to announce a smaller sedan
that will cost half the price of the
Model S that will be the real brake firm